the movie Snowden starring Joseph  gordon-levitt opens tomorrow and yeah  yeah and this has been kind of a story  to prepare this is true to prepare for  his role as whistleblower Edward Snowden  Joseph gordon-levitt met with Snowden at  an undisclosed location for four hours  to learn how to mimic his voice that is  a true story and a lot of people are  talking about it  well leizerman after seeing the trailer  I have to say I wish he had studied  Snowden just a little bit harder you  ever again land on those legs as a bone  some kind of powder any other ways to  serve your country why do you even join  the CIA I'd like to help my country make  a difference in the world  deputy director of the NSA offered me a  new position the NSA is really tracking  every cell phone in the world hey hey  they're gonna figure out what I've done  they're gonna come for me  they're gonna come for all of you to  snow dad  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  you